bruno le maire ministre de l'agriculture
et mousquetaires de la majorité avec vos
amis copé baroin et jacob le club des 4
dit on est donc l'invitée de preuves par
3 bonsoir parcours en trois étapes ce
soir bien sûr en toute fin d'émission
perrine tarneaud de public sénat vous
interrogera pour tenter de démêler le
fil de votre parcours entre engagement
politique bien sûr mais aussi
aspirations intellectuelle ambitions
forgé aux côtés de dominique de villepin
catherine chatignoux des échos nous
rejoindra dans un quart d'heure pour
évoquer notamment la crise agricole et
ses conséquences sur l'unité de l'europe
l'europe qui juge si mal la france en ce
moment vous l'européen convaincu
reconnaîtrez peut-être que la france a
certes un tort depuis quelques semaines
mais d'abord bruno le maire quelle est
votre réaction à l'annoncé par bruxelles
du lancement d'une procédure
d'infraction au sujet des roms
je crois surtout que ce qui est
important à retenir dans les décisions
européennes c'est la reconnaissance que
il n'y a pas eu de la part de la france
de non respect des règles européennes en
matière d'expulsions tels que j'étais
conduite depuis plusieurs mois et je
tiens à leur dire de manière très claire
qu'est ce que nous faisons avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement et je prends
toute ma part là-dedans parce que c'est
des décisions qui sont gouvernementale
collective et que chacun doit assumer
nous faisons respecter la règle de droit
républicaine je pense qu'il est très
important là je m'exprime presque plus
comme élu local que comme ministre très
important que chaque français aient le
sentiment que la règle de droit est la
même pour tous partout sur le trait de
territoire record de bruxelles a plus
qu'un doute puisque la menace la france
d'infraction pour non respect des textes
en vigueur le moment on est dans les
menaces mais ce que je sais c'est que la
règle de droit républicaine doit
appliquer partout sur le territoire et
ce que je vois ce que j'entends chez moi
en normandie près d'evreux dans les
petites communes rurales ce que nous
demande des citoyens c'est de faire
respecter le droit par tous sans
discrimination sans stigmatiser qui que
ce soit bien faisons en sorte que
lorsqu'un territoire est occupé de
manière illégale force soit laissé aux
droits et à la république sont les
campagnes et contre bruxelles c'est la
règle de droit républicaine qui doit
être appliqué sans stigmatiser qui que
ce soit sans discriminer qui que ce soit
mais en faisant très attention que cette
règle de droit soit bien respecté la
procédure annoncée aujourd'hui par
bruxelles est ce que vous êtes choqués
voire scandalisé moi ce qui me choque
c'est quand on ne respecte pas la règle
de droit l'union européenne est dans son
rôle la commission européenne est dans
son rôle j'ai pas à commenter
spécialement les décisions de la
commission ce que je souhaite c'est que
sur notre territoire comme le décide le
miz intérieur on a qu à être prémunie
sous ma couette le président de la
république lorsqu'il y a des territoires
qui sont occupés illégalement par
quelques populations que ce soit et bien
le droit soit respecté alors et que les
exclusions soient prononcées il y a des
doutes manifestement au sein de la
commission a notamment de l'accordéon
diane reddick je pense qu'on saura y
répondre oui
reding ne s'est pas illustré par les
propos qu'elle a tenus à l'encontre de
la france je dois dire que j'ai été
personnellement choqué par les
comparaisons qu'elle a pu faire entre
les décisions prises par la france et
certains épisodes de l'histoire du 20e
siècle moi ce que je souhaite de magna
une fois encore très pragmatique c'est
qu'en france lorsqu'il ya grève de droit
on se contente pas de la commenter on se
contente pas de dire qu'elle existe on
l'a fasse respecter vienne reding la
commissaire à la justice reste très
ferme elle évoque même une infraction
pour discrimination cette infraction là
est possible est ce que vous la jugez
isolé au sein de la commission moi je ne
vois pas de discrimination dans
l'application de la règle de droit il ya
eu une circulaire qui a été critiqué et
qui était justement critiqué je dois le
reconnaître mais l'erreur a été corrigée
très rapidement par brice hortefeux est
ce que nous faisons actuellement une
fois encore et j'insiste lourdement
parce que je crois que c'est très
important pour la cohésion républicaine
du pays c'est l'application des règles
les mêmes pour tous je vois pas pourquoi
certains pourrait se dispenser de
l'application de la règle de droit dans
notre pays bruno le maire le
gouvernement et la majorité sont dans
l'expectative est-ce que vous rêvez vous
de matignon matignon une maison que vous
connaissez si bien et je rêve eux la
moitié m'en laisse peu de temps je vous
fais une confidence je suis un ministre
de l'agriculture heureux je suis très
fier d'occuper ce poste-là qu'à un poste
difficile qui est un poste compliqué
mais dans lequel on tire beaucoup de
plaisir et beaucoup de reconnaissance
dans le contact qu'on a que
l'agriculteur c'est richard et tous les
jours on a vraiment passé un peu plus de
jouer mais c'est un très beau métier
c'est une très belle mission et je suis
très heureux je me pose pas beaucoup
plus de questions mais on parle pour
vous alors certains se disent evo10
c'est matignon c'est pour toi ce coup là
est ce que vous y croyez est ce que vous
les voyez politique c'est les
commentaires parisien vous savez il ya
quelques jours j'étais à biarritz
aujourd'hui parlementaire justement
c'est de son ouvre dans les deux vont se
trouve que j'ai une ferme au pays basque
à saint-pée-sur-nivelle
quand je sors de ma ferme à saint pée
sur nivelle et que je discute avec mes
voisins et y en a pas un qui me parle de
remaniement le fermier du coin la côte
est il est là avec ses brebis il parle
de ses difficultés il me parle pas du
remaniement et je pense du la raison
vous avez équidés plein de bon sens
surtout
biarritz se rencontrer des
parlementaires de l'ump qui je vous en
parlais du remaniement annoncé vous
figurez donc dit-on parmi les premiers
ministrables est-ce que ça oblige à se
préparer non je vous répond très
clairement je ne prépare pas à quoi que
ce soit je fais mon travail de ministre
de l'agriculture il faut encore s'ils
voulaient garder la tête froide le mieux
à faire c'est de sortir de chez eux ou à
saint pée sur nivelle de discuter avec
l'un de vous deux vous promener dans
evreux ou à côté d'evreux de circuler
dans ma région haute-normandie pas une
personne que je rencontre sur le terrain
ne me pas de remaniement ou si ça
arrivait est ce que vous vous sentiriez
prêt si ça arrive cela arrivera et
personne ne sait ce qui peut se produire
la décision est la marque tient pas la
décision appartient exclusivement
totalement constitutionnellement et je
suis respectueux bien entendu de la
constitution au président de la
république au présent admis qsssl nous
avons un très bon premier ministre qui
fait son travail
nous avons à présent la république qui a
toutes les cartes entre les mains et qui
sera seul à décider lorsque vous avez
déjà beaucoup de décisions à prendre
pour vous même est-ce quelqu'un quand
vous êtes mise à la culture il vaut
mieux ne pas s'occuper des nations qui
ne concerne que d autres mets donc je
disais vous connaissez bien matinée on
vous avait été le directeur de cabinet
de dominique de villepin est dans votre
carrière on y reviendra un peu plus tard
un bruno le maire vous avez franchi très
vite très jeunes de haute marche
celle-ci ne vous ferai pas peur je
connais bien matignon c'est une évidence
quand il a été directeur de cabinet à
matignon vous connaissez bien la maison
mais ce n'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui
et ce n'est pas ma décision je le dis
vraiment avec beaucoup de conviction ce
qu'on attend de moi aujourd'hui ce
captant la majorité le présent avis
public le premier ministre sait que je
fasse bien mon travail de misery culture
je peux vous dire que ça suffit un homme
pour une journée bien remplie l'instant
vous n'êtes pas comme christine lagarde
je ne suis pas prête pour matignon et
donc on verra en semant suivra les
rumeurs et puis la décision si ce n'est
pas à moi de décider de touche là c'est
la décision du président de la
république seul on dit que on dit
l'enfer de matignon vous l'avez connu un
vous y avait été plongé ça ne vous
découvre agirait pas plus que cela donc
moi j'ai vécu aux côtés de dominique de
villepin une très belle expérience dans
les deux années qui l'a fait à matignon
que je pense que c'était un très bon
premier ministre
je crois que il en garde lui même un
très bon souvenir alors vous avez salué
françois fillon comme un très bon
premier ministre pourtant on sent qu'il
prépare lui-même son départ pour preuve
la récente interview retentissante à
france 2 vous l'avez bien sûr suivi il
se voit il le dit lui-même relever de
nouveaux challenges ou serait-il selon
vous le plus utile pour renforcer les
chances de la victoire en 2012 puisque
c'est aussi votre moteur on en parlera
dans cette émission ou serait-il le plus
utile va partait du principe que
françois fillon va quitter son poste moi
je n'en sais absolument rien c'est au
président de la république seul de le
décider nos institutions sont bien
faites les décisions sont équitablement
répartie est d'accord mais vous plaidez
pour un nouvel élan pour que la gauche
ne remporte pas la victoire en 2012 donc
vous pourriez nous dire là ce soir
peut-être que ça passe par un nouveau
premier ministre puisque vous plaidé
pour un gouvernement resserré et
notamment un nouvel élan ça passe
d'abord par la mise en place d'un
certain nombre de convictions ça passe
par des décisions ça passe par une
politique que nous assumons tous
totalement beaucoup plus que par des
changements de personnes ici ou là c'est
pas le véritable sujet moi qu'est ce que
je constate aujourd'hui ce que je
constate aujourd'hui qui me frappe le
plus c'est que la situation économique
de la france est en train de s'améliorer
considérablement que nous avons une
croissance qui va atteindre 1 12 5%
contre les 0,75 qui avait été attendu
que nous avons créé 60 mille emplois
nets cette année en 2010 que nous tenons
le bon bout et je pourrais le dire aussi
dans la culture nous tenons le bon bout
moi la seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'on puisse dire aux français les yeux
dans les yeux nous sommes sortis de la
crise la situation va mieux l'emploi
s'améliore nous avons rempli le travail
moi j'estime que les décisions qui ont
été prises depuis deux ans par le
présent dans le public est pas le
premier ministre dans une situation de
crise exceptionnelle ont été les bonnes
décisions les décisions sages les
décisions qui nous ont permis de sortir
la tête hors des pays européens de la
crise c'est pas rien mais je reviens à
ma question sur votre ambition éventuels
ou les supputations vous concernant
bruno le maire est ce que cette
perspective peut-être matignon je ne
sais pas je suis très content que les
gens des ambitions pour moi est parfait
est ce que c'est vous savez ne vous
prive pas d'une certaine liberté de
temps parce que vous avez été quand même
assez sévère avec le chef de l'état
récemment dans cette tribune de la
fameuse bande des quatre puisque vous
réclamer un changement de ton comique
conan je me considère que nous avons été
sévères ces données que son oblique vous
avez donné pour le moins de 100 jours de
retard vous savez c'est pas mon
caractère de donner des leçons au chef
de l'état alors je suis contente de la
royal au chef de l'état et respectueux
naturellement du chef de l'état le
message principal qui était dans cette
tribune je tiens quand même à le
rappeler c'est que quatre personnes du
monde politique de la majorité qui se
connaissent bien les amis de longue date
10 nous voulons soutenir le présent la
république pour 2012 c'était ça le
message principal comme c'est un message
positif bien entendu il rentre par une
oreille et ressort par l'autre mais
c'est ça le message principal ensuite
nous souhaitons effectivement poursuivre
l'action accentué l'action que j'ai
conduite au service des français pour
que nous puissions nous présenter en
2012 dans les meilleures conditions
possibles alors pour l'instant le
principal écueil ou l'apprend
principales réformes qu'il reste à
accomplir peut-être l'unique même c'est
celle des retraites bruno le maire
dominique de villepin conseil lui le
compromis il dit c'est cette réforme
passe telle qu'elle est bien la majorité
le paiera très cher en 2012 il se
souvient qu'au bout du blocage sur le
cpe vous avez le même souvenir est ce
qu'il dit vrai je crois qu'on n'est pas
du tout dans la situation où on était
avec le cpe on est sur une réforme dont
les français ont très majoritairement
compris qu'elle était absolument
nécessaire pour le pays qu'il rejette
parce que c'est du bon sens et se pose
est celle selon les mais c'est normal
quand vous demander un effort aux
français surtout dans une période de
sortie de crise on leur demande de
cotiser plus longtemps forcément c'est
un effort personne ne peut prendre sa
légère et se dire tiens ça va passer
facilement ce ne représente aucun effort
pour personne si c'est un effort et on
mesure cet effort là mais cet effort il
est nécessaire parce que sinon nous
n'arriverons pas à financer nos
retraites par répartition et il est
légitime parce que à partir du moment où
nous vivons plus longtemps et en mieux
dans notre pays à partir du moment où il
ya moins de personnes pour cotiser pour
les retraites il est légitime qu'on
reporte l'âge légal de la retraite à 62
ans et qu'on reporte l'âge à partir
duquel la décote ne s'applique plus de
65 à 67 ans à ces deux bornes quand t'es
fixé mais je souhaite qu'on s'en tienne
à ça en revanche écouter ce qui se dit
dans la rue écoutez les manifestants
regardez ce que disent les
parlementaires notamment au sénat ça me
paraît utile et les propositions qui ont
été faites sur les femmes notamment qu'
à des avancées qui ont été faites très
important sur la pénibilité en ramenant
de 20 à 10% à
avancer cette suspension là il y en a
d'autres qui eux des sénateurs et qui
sont moins bien avec les bus sénat doit
nous permettre d'avancer encore vers ce
qui est le coeur de cette réforme c'est
à dire réforme juste une réforme
équitable même si les rendra juste selon
vous je pense que l'équipe
fondamentalement juste et équitable
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui mais si on
peut améliorer encore les choses pour
les femmes sur la base des propositions
que feront les sénateurs eric woerth
d'ailleurs l'a indiqué je crois que ce
serait une trés bonne et vous même par
exemple vous seriez favorable à ce qu'on
maintienne la borne des 65 ans
l'âge de départ sans décote pour les
femmes ayant eu par exemple trois
enfants oui ou non je pense que pour
l'instant il ya une vraie logique dans
les deux bornes que sont les 62 ans
comme âge légal et 67 ans pour l'âge de
la décote que à l'intérieur de ces deux
bornes dans les fermes en fasse plus
pour les femmes sur la base de
propositions qui peut être formé par les
sénateurs ça nous paraît très
intéressant est juste ou non est ce que
le gouvernement prendrait un monde
néanmoins un risque en restant
inflexible comme averti dominique de
villepin prenez toujours un risque quand
vous prenez des décisions mais difficile
mais le pire des risques pour notre
majorité ce serait de ne pas prendre de
risques supplémentaires et de ne pas
assumer de décision on a pris des
décisions difficiles sur les retraites
je crois que c'est une bonne chose on a
pris des décisions très difficiles sur
l'agriculture pour aller vers plus de
compétitivité et en opérant une
véritable révolution dans la conception
de la culture en france mais c'est
nécessaire on a pris un risque et
valérie pécresse l'a parfaitement assumé
en décidant d'aller vers l'autonomie des
universités mais le résultat c'est que
l'université française aujourd'hui sont
plus attractive qu'elle ne l'était hier
nous avons intérêt à prendre des risques
elle risque l'usure et les justes
calculer mais je crois que c'est
l'honneur notre majorité de prendre des
risques et de faire bouger le pays en
sachant dire non en sachant écouter et
dian d'abord et lorsque nous estimons
que cela pourrait entamer le coeur de la
réforme savoir comme l'a dit françois
fillon dire non très bien encore un mot
sur dominique de villepin avait
peut-être assez qu'on vous interroge
toujours sur lui mais ça va quand même
un petit peu dans les vidéos sur kompass
vous en prend pas est-ce que vous pensez
que
il a des chances en 2012 puisque les
sondages montrent quand même qu'à droite
il ferait un carton plein moi je fais de
commentaires là dessus et le premier
c'est que comme je vais indiquer d'un
tribune et j'assume chaque mot en
général de ce que j'écris nous nous
rassemblions la majorité tous derrière
le présent la république s'il décide de
se représenter en 2012 je crois que
c'est la sagesse et la raison pour notre
majorité oui la deuxième commentaire que
je tiens fait de villepin a pris
décision que je crois une bonne décision
en reprenant sa carte à l'ump cet été en
s'inscrivant dans la majorité
présidentielle ne dormant pas cool non
seulement à sortir dans ces wagons sort
politique oui l'acte qu'il a posé un
acte important elle a repris sa carte à
l'ump je considère que c'est un des
grands talents de l'ump l'a prouvé à
matignon l'a prouvé commises affaires
étrangères présentera nous aurions tout
intérêt à lui faire la place qui lui
revient de telle sorte qu'il puisse
apporter à la majorité très bien un
geste qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour le
faire revenir vraiment leur ferveur on
peut faire beaucoup de l'unil occupent
toute la place dans la majorité moi j'ai
pas d'habitude en étant membre d'une
majorité de me dire qu'il ya les talons
va les laisser à l'extérieur nous
critiquer mieux vaut tendre la main lui
faire reprendre toute sa place au sein
de la majorité écouter les critiques qui
peut faire qui sont parfois je le
reconnais un peu violente mais un
prochain gouvernement quand même mais
c'est pas une question de place c'est
pas un honneur la soude poste mais je
crois que il a toute sa place dans notre
majorité s'ils n'avaient pas d'ailleurs
ils n'auraient pas repris sa carte
annuelle alors bono le maire et
catherine chatting des échos va nous
rejoindre
dans quelques instants mais avant cela
nous allons tenter de percer le mystère
s'il y en a de cette fameuse bande des
cartes que vous avez évoqué bande des
quatre à laquelle vous appartenez donc
je le rappelle trois chiraquiens et puis
pour vous je vais dire quoi un néo
villepiniste je n'aime pas et ce dic et
vous savez marie brême au fond regarde
les bébés chirac les quatre
mousquetaires les dalton peu importe
leur surnom leur pacte politique part
d'un simple constat on est plus forts
1,4 que sur le sol surtout en politique
ils ont donc décidé de se la jouer
collectif ces quatre individualités jean
françois copé le chef des députés ump
ennemi juré du patron du parti xavier
bertrand françois baroin ministre du
budget et fils spirituel de jacques
chirac christian jacob lui aussi proche
de l'ancien président de la république
et bruno le maire diplomate est élevé en
politique dans le sillage de villepin
c'est l'histoire d'un groupe d'amitié
des amis camarades compères copains
compagnons des potes donc qui ensemble
lors de déjeuners rassemblent leurs
ambitions communes pour paraît-il mieux
servir leur camp pour mieux servir la
france nous proposons des pistes pour la
france et c'est ensuite un engagement
d'une génération qui a pris qui n'a pas
oublié les sources de division et qui ne
veut pas rentrer dans le jeu d'une
division qui pourrait être mortelle pour
ceux qui se retrouvent dans nos valeurs
pas de division cela reste à voir car si
le quatuor s'est clairement prononcé
pour une nouvelle candidature de nicolas
sarkozy à la prochaine présidentielle
les bébés chirac espère bien porter l'un
des leurs jean françois copé à la tête
de l'ump
voilà catherine châtaignes ou des échos
nous a rejoint bonsoir catherine on va
passer aller directement du club des
quatre au club des 27 avec la crise
agricole qui s'aggrave et qui est
également synonyme de crise européenne
oui enfin moi j'aurais bien voulu
commencer d'abord par parler de la
situation des agriculteurs français
quand on regarde les chiffres des
revenus des agriculteurs depuis deux ans
c'est effarant ils ont perdu 34% leurs
revenus en moyenne en 2009 et 20 % en
2008 alors tenter de remédier à des
situations signant des chèques ici et là
mais sur le fond quelles sont les
raisons de cette dégradation bon vous
verrez que en 2010 je touche du bois
les résultats devraient être bien
meilleurs dans quasiment toutes les
filières à l'exception sans doute de la
filière de l'élevage qui ma
préoccupation première donc nous sommes
bien comme en matière de finances
publiques en matière de croissance qu'en
matière d'emploi grâce aux décisions
prises par le gouvernement parc
république sur la bonne voie
moi je crois que nous avons
impérativement besoin de faire prendre à
l'agriculture française comme nous le
faisons depuis plusieurs mois un vrai
tournant qui est le tournant de la
compétitivité de sa capacité à affronter
la concurrence notamment allemandes et
internationales de façon à lui permettre
de rester un des secteurs stratégiques
français et je vais vous dire
l'allemagne concurrencer les produits
agricoles quiz c'est effectivement une
des grandes nouveautés personne n'avait
vu venir l'allemagne comme concurrent
des agriculteurs français il se trouve
que sur la production de l'élevage
production porcine sur les fruits et
légumes vraiment n'attendez pas
l'allemagne sur le lait sur le lait eh
bien nous voyons l'allemagne nous
tailler des croupières dans certaines
filières
incroyable ma conviction c'est que la
france a tous les atouts pour réussir et
d'ailleurs que nous tenons le bon bout
dans la fia laitières dans les fruits et
légumes dans la viticulture nous sommes
en train de gagner des parts de marché à
l'exportation notamment en chine dans la
filière des grandes cultures les
céréales ou les prix ont fortement
augmenté nous pouvons être et rester les
meilleurs en europe nous avons tous les
moyens pour réussir simplement il faut
pas mentir aux agriculteurs moi quand
j'entends certains qui disent notamment
certains responsables du parti
socialiste qui disent aux producteurs de
lait il faut qu on vous paye 400 euros
la tonne mais je me demande comment en
conscience sérieusement on peut dire ça
un producteur de lait chacun sait bien
que le lait n'atteint pas 400 euros la
tonne chacun sait bien que les pouvoirs
publics n'ont pas la capacité entre
leurs mains de payer la tonne de lait
400 euros alors qu'au mieux la tante 320
à 330 euros et chacun sait bien que si
jamais nous arrivions à payer 400 euros
la tonne de lait qu'est ce que ferait
les industriels ils iraient chercher le
relais en allemagne et il mettrait tous
les producteurs de lait français en
grande difficulté moi je tiens un
discours de vérité aux agriculteurs
français tout droit vers une
libéralisation des quotas puisque les
quotas vont disparaître on va
libéralisation des quotas on renonce à
ses quotas qui fixait une quantité de
lait administratif pays par pays aucun
état membre ne souhaite revenir là
dessus la france non plus simplement ce
que je souhaite c'est que on ne jette
pas le bébé avec l'eau du bain c'est à
dire qu'on ne dise pas on abandonne les
quotas qu'ils ont mais rien en face moi
ce que je souhaite c'est que
effectivement nous avons donnions des
quotas qui n'ont pas apporté la preuve
de leur efficacité mais que en face nous
mettions nous sommes en train de gagner
cette partie une régulation des marchés
je ne crois pas à la libéralisation
totale des marchés agricoles je pense
que ce serait une faute politique et
donc je me bats depuis maintenant douze
mois pour qu'il y ait une vraie
régulation c'est à dire la capacité
d'intervenir quand il ya une crise la
capacité à stabiliser les prix la
capacité à garantir un revenu décent
mais je restais le rôle de la pac de
protéger les agriculteurs contre les
à-coups des marchés alors que ce soit
comme la politique agricole c'est ce que
je souhaite aussi mais tous n'avaient
pas la même conception en europe du rôle
de la pac je vous rappelle qu'il ya un
an quels étaient les propositions sur la
table la commission avait dit le budget
de la pac on le réduit de 30 à 40% si
vous imaginez ce que ça veut dire pour
le revenu des agriculteurs français la
régulation on refuse catégoriquement
l'allemagne et la france elle était sur
deux positions totalement divergents un
an après en septembre 2010 où on en est
le budget de la pac tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'il serait quand
même plus raisonnable de le préserver la
régulation des marchés
efficients un consensus entre 20 et
amant pour dire il faut maintenir le
budget de la pac tel qu'il est la
régulation des marchés à mieux répartir
le répartir sans doute mais demain -
pour les fronts la régulation était un
véritable gros mots en europe
aujourd'hui c'est un point de consensus
à l'initiative de la france entre les
pays européens quant à la france et
l'allemagne qui étaient divisés sur les
questions agricoles après un an de
négociations nous avons signé une
position commune entre la france et
l'allemagne sur l'avenir de la pac c'est
la meilleure nouvelle que les paysans
français pouvait avoir au cours de ces
derniers mois il faut encore il faut qu
à l'unanimité les états membres une
majorité faute de majorité qualifiée
mais je peux vous dire que je continue à
me battre et tant que nous n'aurons pas
tout acquis en matière d aide pour les
agriculteurs français de préservation de
la pac je continuerai à me battre une
petite question au passage sur le budget
national cette fois votre budget à
l'agriculture est en baisse comme
quasiment tous les médias en légère
augmentation c'est un bon alors il
s'agit de l'un des deux lui pour cent
oui mais l'ado chile 3,2 quelques en mai
en baisse alors si m les rendements
agricoles et la mission agricole au sens
large il est en légère où je l'avais glu
% pour une raison qui est très simple
c'est que le président la république et
le premier ministre ont fait un choix
stratégique qui est de dire nous croyons
dans l'avenir de l'agriculture française
ils ont connu comme vous venez de le
rappeler très justement un effondrement
de leurs revenus comme aucun autre
secteur économique dans l'inconnu en
2009 imaginez ce que c'est de perdre 50%
de son revenu imaginez votre salaire
divisé par deux ce que cela veut dire
donc nous avons décidé avec le premie
nice et avec faisant la république
d'accorder un effort particulier aux
agriculteurs pour le budget 2011 avec
des plans de soutien des plans de
développement des filières et un
accompagnement des filières les plus en
difficulté sur l'europe alors sur
l'europe vous parler de terreur de la
crise des roms vous avez un peu évoqué
tout à l'heure la façon dont vous aviez
de traverser cette crise jugé un peu les
événements mais moi j'aurai savoir plus
précisément si vous auriez gérer cette
crise comme votre successeur pierre
lellouche la faire
sur le long il a très bien géré très
franchement j'ai pas à faire des
critiques sur ce qu'a fait mon
successeur je trouve que pierre s'est
très bien débrouillé qu'il a su
expliquer la position française aux
autorités européennes notamment à la
commission et je le redis je pense qu'il
faut que nous fassions très attention à
ce risque qui existe en europe d'une
montée du populisme et des extrêmes que
nous voyons dans un certain nombre
d'états membres le populisme les
extrêmes se nourrissent de quoi la faute
de qui se nourrissent du laxisme et de
l'absence du respect des règles
républicaines lorsque vous ne faites pas
respecté le droit lorsqu'un certain
nombre de citoyens ont le sentiment
qu'il ya des règles à deux vitesses
lorsque en plus la crise frappe en terme
de chômage en termes d'emploi en termes
de revenus là vous nourrissez le
populisme là vous nourrissez les
extrêmes quand en revanche vous assumez
l'application stricte de la règle de
droit
je pense que vous dégager la voie un
consensus république alors vous craignez
la montée du populisme et qui est
notable effectivement dans un certain
nombre de pays européens bruno le maire
je veux montrer la nouvelle couverture
de newsweek de cette semaine c'est une
couverture qui me choque profondément
alors elle dit que donc il y à une
poussée des extrêmes en europe une ligne
dure à droite et la personne qui incarne
ce populisme c'est nicolas sarkozy c'est
une couverture qui me choque
profondément comme d'autres couvertures
des mêmes journaux anglo saxons avaient
pu me choquer au moment de la crise en
irak lorsqu'on accuse les français de
tous les maux elle est accusée le
présent de la république qui fait
respecter la règle de droit ni plus ni
moins de populisme ou de xénophobie
comme le fait newsweek j'ai vu ça je
trouve ça tout à fait inacceptable et je
pèse mes termes qu'est ce que c'est le
nom de crise il ya un vent d'être le
président de la république fait
respecter le droit républicain
moi je suis élu local je vous l'avais
dit au conseil régional najimy campagne
francs dans les comptes et à bruxelles
mais je vous assure que c'est la vérité
écouter ce que disent les maires de
gauche comme de droite qu'est ce que
c'est lorsque vous avez un campement
illégal à la sortie de votre commune de
600 de 700 habitants lorsque le droit
n'est pas respecté et que le campement
illégal
est alors même que les citoyens de cette
même commune vont être sanctionnés parce
qu'ils ne respectent pas eu la moindre
infraction au code de la route de temps
sony rome quelques instants bruno le
maire est ce que vous avez toujours été
très à l'aise avec ce qui s'est passé
depuis cet été ce durcissement
sécuritaire l'idée par exemple de te
d'élire les juges la déchéance de
nationalité dont on débat en ce moment à
l'assemblée nationale vous êtes toujours
à la chose il ya des choses qui sont
très diverses moi je suis là l'aise donc
vous êtes allés avec des principes qui
sont simples je suis à l'aise avec le
respect de la règle de droit je suis à
l'aise lorsque le contrat de sécurité
qui est un contrat moral que nous avons
conclus avec les français en 2007 et
respecté en revanche je dois dire que
lorsque dans une circulaire on rajoute
spécifiquement les roms eh bien je me
félicite que le ministre l'intérieur
brice hortefeux le corrige rappelle que
vous regretterez que je n'ai rien
qu'avec les niçois toujours en poste
chassez la responsabilité du ministre de
l'intérieur j'ai pas à juger de la façon
dont il le gère ses troupes l'erreur est
humaine elle peut arriver à tout le
monde ce que je dis simplement c'est que
il est bien il est juste de la part de
brice hortefeux d'avoir corrigé
rapidement cette circulaire parce que
nous n'avons pas vocation à pointer du
doigt les uns ou les autres mais faisons
très attention nous avons un contrat
moral sur la sécurité avec les français
il faut le respecter il faut des
résultats et nous avons l'obligation de
garantir à tous les français notamment
les plus faibles d'entre eux que le
droit républicain le même pour tous
catherine hill de respect de la règle de
droit s'il y en a une que les états
membres de l'europe n'ont pas respecté
c'est celle de des règles du pacte de
stabilité et de respect de la bonne
gestion des finances publiques
aujourd'hui la commission a fait des
propositions pour essayer de mieux
encadrer les dépenses
envisager des sanctions financières et
non alors toute une batterie de
sanctions sont prévues ça va être
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre comme
d'habitude est ce que vous pensez que
c'est la bonne voie pour obliger les
états à plus de vertu il y était
attention à ce que l'union européenne ne
se résume pas à une batterie de règles
de normes et de sanctions l'europe vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure c'est l'un
des éléments clés de mon engagement
politique
je fais de la politique parce que je
crois un certain nombre de convictions
pour la france parce que j'aime mon pays
et pour l'europe parce que je crois dans
l'europe et je crois dans une europe qui
présentent des projets pour les jeunes
pour les étudiants des projets pour la
culture les projets pour l'innovation
pour la recherche des projets pour
l'agriculture tout ce que je vois sortir
de l'europe aujourd'hui c'est des règles
et des contraintes c'est le bâton c'est
la condamnation c'est des accusations
contre la france ce n'est pas
l'allemagne ce n'est pas l'europe que
j'aime je le dis très clairement
l'europe que j'aime c'est l'europe qui a
des ambitions c'est l'europe est ouverte
c'est l'europe qui est généreuse et qui
est capable de construire des politiques
qu'ils puissent enthousiasmé les
citoyens européens moi l'europe qui me
dit si jamais vous respectez pas la
règle de stabilité du pacte budgétaire
on va les prendre l'argent de vos
paysans désolé je vous parle franchement
c'est pas mon truc moi ce que je vois
c'est qu'en france nous avons fait des
efforts budgétaires sans précédent
françois baron a fait ce matin
l'excellente présentation en conseil des
ministres il a rappelé que nous allions
réduire le déficit budgétaire entre 2010
et 2011 de 7,7 pour cent du pib' à 6% du
pib c'est une marge considérable à l
ange bienvenue la pression sur pressions
européennes c'est un choix politique
nationale a su me répond oubliée et à
bruxelles je leur dis avec beaucoup de
force
l'europe que j'aime est une europe qui
propose est une europe qui inspire en
europe qui enthousiasme est pas une
europe qui sanctionne qui condamne qui
pointe du doigt les uns aux autres vous
qui connaissez bien l'allemagne s'est
tout de même bien sous la pression des
aliments que l'europe toute entière est
appelé à faire plus de rigueur mais je
crois qu'on surestime totalement le rôle
de l'allemagne en la matière l'allemagne
elle pratique effectivement une vertu
budgétaire et nous avons décidé c'est
une décision de la république qui me
paraît une excellente décision de mieux
coordonner nos politiques budgétaires
entre la france et l'allemagne quand
j'étais secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes j'étais le premier à dire il
faudrait que le ministre du budget aille
en allemagne présenté le budget français
et changer que son homologue allemand
sur ce sujet là nous le faisons très
bonne chose
plus on ira vers un travail en commun
avec l'allemagne mieux on se portera
mais là aussi n'accusons pas l'allemagne
de tous les maux c'est pas l'allemagne
qui met la rigueur budgétaire par tous
qui exige forcément des contraintes
supplémentaires elle a une vraie rigueur
budgétaire elle a une capacité à bien
son budget dont on peut s'inspirer mais
je ne crois pas que ce soit le rôle de
la commission de systématiquement
proposer des sanctions supplémentaires
merci à catherine en tous les cas vous
militez vous avec vos amis de la bande
des quatre un jour pour l'expression
pour un pacte nouveau entre la france et
l'allemagne devaient être chagriné alors
des liens distendus en ce moment entre
paris et berlin entre nicolas sarkozy et
angela merkel qui se sont chamaillés sur
les roms on y revient en tête devient
comme un géant du tabac je commence et
je vais tout eu des soucis à part
rapporté démonter il sera un des
ministres du gouvernement qui connaît le
mieux l'allemagne c'est un pays que
j'aime profondément que je connais bien
dont j'admire la culture et dans lequel
je me rends environ toutes les trois
semaines qu'est ce que je constate
regardez la question agricole il n'y a
jamais eu de position commune entre la
france et l'allemagne depuis la création
de la pac j'ai subi un revers lundi il
ya quinze jours une position commune
entre la france et l'allemagne soient
bien de la pac avec le soutien de la
chancelière et du président de la
république donc je crois qu'on exagère
là aussi les bisbilles les petites
irritations ici ou là et qu'on ne voit
pas le mouvement global sur
l'agriculture rapprochement sur le
budget rapprochement sur la convergence
fiscale rapprochement sur la
coordination des politiques économiques
rapprochement on tient la bonne
direction aller avant que perrine
tarneaud nous rejoignons va tenter donc
d'en savoir un peu plus sur vous avec
une chrono le maire votre parcours
d'intellectuels en politique vous n'avez
pas fait sensation uniquement avec cette
tribune politique au début du mois qu'on
évoquait dès le début de cette émission
vous connaît également comme auteur voir
comme écrivain tam tran huy
les producteurs en colère les bottes
dans la gadoue et les prises d'otages
laitière ah c'est sûr bono le maire vous
ne vous imaginez pas à l'agriculture
vous c'était plutôt la littérature les
couloirs de l'école normale supérieure
et un début de thèse sur proust est
d'ailleurs le temps ne vous a pas effacé
de la mémoire de vos professeurs c'était
un élève parfait
nombreux
mais comme vous le dites vous même dans
votre dernier livre on devient rarement
ce que l'imagination nous incline à
devenir et c'est vrai que la réalité
vous a vite rattrapé l'université ne
satisfaisait pas vos ambitions vous lui
avez vite préféré sciences po l'ena
sauvetage pour aller plus loin vers des
situations qui socialement
devenait beaucoup plus considérés vous
voilà aujourd'hui auteur déjà de livres
à votre actif où vous vous présentiez en
observateur des puissants entre jacques
chirac nicolas sarkozy et dominique de
villepin votre mentor aujourd'hui
ministre vos ambitions politiques
satisfaite retrouveriez vous vos
appétits littéraire votre prochain livre
un essai très personnel sur votre
engagement dans la mesure où blitz ce
qui signerait même les débuts d'un
écrivain problème voilà c'est perrine
tarneaud qui s'interrogent maintenant
sur vous même
alors qui est votre mentor en politique
moi j'ai commencé à faire de la
politique avec dominique de villepin
donc je lui dois beaucoup mais ensuite
j'ai un parcours qui est effectivement
assez original joue beaucoup de milles
de villepin je dois beaucoup à jean
louis debré
circonscription que je vois souvent
parce qu'il me donne des conseils très
fréquemment et je dois beaucoup au
président de la république qui m'a fait
confiance qui m'a confié le poste de
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes qui était un poste difficile
puis effectivement à ma grande surprise
je le reconnais le post on peut pas trop
sinon ma surprise mais j'ai découvert
après tous les charmes du métier le
poste de ministre de la culture je dois
beaucoup à ces trois personnes je pense
que un parcours un peu improbable à
droite en si peu de temps de passer de
ces parcours original vous aimez les
trois de personnalités ça veut dire vous
refusez de choisir votre mentor mais
parce que pourquoi est ce qu'on fait de
la politique moi c'est une question que
je me pose pas tous les jours
heureusement parce qu'un pas tout le
temps de se poser ces questions-là mais
c'est une question à laquelle il faut
revenir souvent je fais de la politique
pour défendre des convictions parce que
je crois un certain nombre de choses mon
pays je crois entendre de choses pour
l'europe et je veux me donner des moyens
de mettre en application ses convictions
et c'est pour cela que je fais de la
politique je le fais pas seul je le fais
avec des amis je le fais avec ce que
vous appelez la bande des quatre les
quatre mousquetaires comme vous voulez
je le fais sous l'autorité du président
de la république et du premier ministre
parce que c'est une aventure collective
la politique je le fais pour les
convictions mais justement comment vous
venez de citer trois hommes comment on
peut passer de l'un à l'autre sans
renier ses valeurs parce que d'abord je
crois que les trois hommes partagent
beaucoup plus de valeur qu'on ne le
croit elle parce que c'est des hommes
qui croient dans la france ce sont des
hommes qui croient dans la force
politique l'incapacité de la politique a
changé les choses c'est un des grands
points communs d'ailleurs entre
dominique de villepin et nicolas sarkozy
et ce sont des hommes qui ont décidé de
changer un certain nombre de choses
entre pays de façon à ce que chaque
citoyen vivent mieux que moi je partage
ses ambitions lors de votre prochain
livre qui va sortir chez gallimard à la
mi-octobre je crois vous parlais
justement des trois vertus qui sont
essentiels selon vous dans la vie
publique alors vous citez l'autorité la
mémoire et la patience on est très loin
du sarkozysme là non on est très proche
de mes convictions et je pense pas qu'on
soit si loin de ce qu'implique le
présent de la république mais je crois
que c'est important à l'heure qui
appelle à une politique publique un peu
moins spectaculaire mais c'est important
de défendre ses convictions et
d'exprimer ses convictions c'est aussi
l'objet de ce livre c'est une façon de
se mettre un instant un tout petit peu
en retrait de la vie publique décide
réfléchir un peu à ce qu'il doit fonder
une action politique aujourd'hui je
crois que la mémoire c'est essentiel
effectivement ce que nous sommes un pays
de mémoire qu'elles soient anciennes et
que l'europe qui est là aussi coeur de
mes convictions et d'abord un continent
de mémoire la patience est important
aussi parce qu'on ne change pas tout du
jour au lendemain et que seule une
action de long terme permet de faire
bouger des choses qui étaient faits sur
les universités ce qui était fait
recevant poids ce qui était fait en
matière agricole donne des résultats sur
le long terme donc je crois beaucoup à
cette vertu là et puis l'autorité qui
pour le coup je crois rejoint certaines
qualités du pendant la république elle
est indispensable si on veut que les
plus faibles soient protégés et si on
veut également que les règles de droit
soit appliqué notre république donc
c'est ce que j'ai expliqué dans ce livre
on le verra à la fin du mois d'octobre
vous écrivez tous les jours au quotidien
j'écris le plus souvent possible je suis
très émue d'ailleurs que vous allez
retrouver jean yves tadié pour le coup
est un vrai mentor intellectuelle c'est
lui qui a dirigé les travaux de maîtrise
des as puis de thèse qui est un
professeur remarquable je tiens à
travers lui à rendre hommage à tous les
professeurs d'université de collèges
d'école auquel on doit énormément
justement est-ce qu'il a été un nouveau
montage dans la vie à un moment donné à
une épaule est charnière oui c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a indiqué très
clairement je dois dire que j'avais
intérêt à poursuivre dans l'écriture à
avancer dans la politique mais peut-être
a laissé tomber d'université il semble
le regretter dans l'interview il dit que
vous avez peut-être choisi peut être un
métier plus exposés aussi mieux
rétribués
on l'aurait privé vous savez on fait pas
fortune dans polisse non je pense même
que lorsqu'on fait des politiques ont
choisi délibérément de renoncer à
faire fortune ou à réussir
financièrement c'est plutôt mon objectif
un objectif une fois encore c'est un
éléphant 2010 excellent prof quand même
un oui mon gars mieux banques etc
ministre aussi il y avait des choses
qu'est ce que vous écrivez chaque jour
est ce que vous lisez proust chaque jour
je lis prouve ce souvent souvent souvent
oui mais en tout cas cette écriture
c'est une discipline que vous imposez
quotidiennement pourquoi finalement
parce que l'action publique a besoin de
s'ancrer dans la réflexion et que
l'action publique qui va de plus en plus
vite qu'ils se reposent sur un septembre
de nouvelles qui tombe très rapidement
qui est faite de crise que vous avez à
gérer quand cette pizza et culture vous
avez beaucoup de crise à gérer elle peut
un certain moment vous faire dévier de
votre cap vous faire dévier de vos choix
fondamentaux la politique repose sur des
choix moraux elle repose sur des
convictions pour le pays elle repose sur
à septembre d'engagement par rapport à
l'histoire de son pays à l'histoire
européenne
je le dis dans mon livre très clairement
ce qui s'est passé pendant tout le xxème
siècle ce qui s'est passé est la shoah
ce qui s'est passé durant la deuxième
guerre mondiale tous à un rôle dans mon
engagement politique je pense qu'il faut
jamais le perdre de vue c'est la
meilleure façon d'éviter les erreurs
donc c'est une réflexion sur votre
engagement politique mais quand même au
quotidien la base c'est l'ambition qui
restent le moteur nos en politique je
crois pas je crois pas ça je suis en
désaccord avec avec cela certains
assument totalement dit ça mais
forcément que lorsque vous faites de la
politique vous avez de l'ambition c'est
normal mais c'est pas forcément le
moteur principal là je sais que certains
disent j'assume totalement mes ambitions
je suis ambitieux et rod lettre moi je
ne dis pas que l'ambition est mon moteur
principal je le dis très clairement j'ai
des convictions j'assemble de choses
auxquelles je crois que je souhaite
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre et c'est plus
ça mon moteur qu'une ambition
personnelle vous avez rappelé votre
appart autres
l'importance pour vous de la mémoire
vous avez cité la choix comment est ce
que vous avez reçu la défense de votre
ami jean françois copé qui est attaqué
par martin hirsch sur le conflit
d'intérêt et jean françois copé dit et
comme martin hirsch mon père ait été
sauvés par des justes est ce que c'était
vraiment la défense n'a pas été choqué
cette récente août confiant sinon c'est
tout à l'heure oui comme le chercheur a
montré je vais vous répondre franchement
fait par viviane reding je vous réponds
très librement d'abord sur deux points
le premier c'est que je fais entièrement
confiance à mon ami jean françois copé
je sais qu'il ne mélange pas les genres
et je sais qu'il fait un partage total
franc et honnête entre ses activités
d'avocat et ses activités de président
de groupe et de député je lui fais une
totale confiance le deuxième point c'est
que je suis de plus en plus surpris dans
le débat public mais que ce soit sur
cette affaire là ou sur d'autres
affaires du mélange des genres entre des
choses qui sont dans le fond pas de très
grande importance ou d'importance
réduite et des événements dramatiques
que ont connu nos pays la france
l'allemagne et d'autres pays voisins et
l'europe laissons ces événements
dramatiques la place qui est la leur
ce sont des événements fondateurs qu'on
a pas à ramener à toutes les sauces dans
tous les événements y compris les
événements de la politique politicienne
je souhaite vraiment que nous évitions
ces comparaisons qui sont en général
malencontreuse voilà ça c'est pour jean
françois copé annoncé les projets wiki
comme de détendre le débat public en
mairie des semaines je vois que
systématiquement en panne après
l'expulsion parle d'un problème de
respect des règles publiques lors le
sujet et tout d'un coup on revient à la
question de la shoah et de
l'extermination des juifs durant la
deuxième guerre mondiale mais c'est
profondément choquant mettons un tout
petit peu de raison et un tout petit peu
d'ordre dans nos raisonnements
intellectuelle et politique pour revenir
un peu à votre départ en politique à
votre ancrage à la conquête finalement
du terrain quand vous avez décidé de
vous lancer dans votre département de
l'eure c'était le début des emmerdes com
vous a dit dominique de villepin est ce
que ça s'est révélé vrai sur le terrain
c'est pas facile je le reconnais de
passer du bureau du directeur de cabinet
du premier ministre pas un poste facile
mais où en règle générale on ne bouge
pas entre les quatre murs de son bureau
rue de varenne au terrain politique où
vous rencontrez des gens qui n'ont
absolument rien à faire et aussi
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
qui se demande légitimement uniquement
si vous allez bien défendre leurs
intérêts et leurs valeurs c'est un vrai
choc
réservez j'ai un peu lisse j'ai dû
forcer ma nature j'ai dû forcer ma
nature je suis beaucoup moins lisse
qu'on ne le pense mais en revanche je
reconnais une certaine réserve et j'ai
dû forcer ma nature je me suis
d'ailleurs très bien d'un premier
meeting où jean françois copé justement
était venu m'accompagner parce qu'il m'a
beaucoup soutenu comme françois baron
était venu me soutenir aussi avec
beaucoup de gentillesse et jean-françois
ma vie des astres du meeting tu sais
savait que son franc parler ça va pas le
faire du tout si tu remontes la travée
sans tendre la main et saluer les gens
il faut que tu ailles vers les gens dans
la 9 qui te ça dure on est un qu'il
crache à la figure mais c'est pas grave
c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire sauter
un très bon jugement est totalement
débarrassé de votre côté techno techno
je pense m'être débarrassé la réserve ça
fait partie de ma nature c'est vrai fait
pas de vagues ce qui vous rend peut-être
matignon compatible aujourd'hui siens
mais je suis pas là pour faire des
vagues vous savez on peut s'agiter faire
des moulinets
je vois ma fonction et ma responsabilité
comme une fonction pour résoudre les
problèmes des personnes dont j'ai la
charge les agriculteurs les pêcheurs
l'industrie agroalimentaire je suis là
pour résoudre des difficultés et pour
fixer un café vous avez un site agréé
conseillons vous aurez encore interrogé
sur l'hypothèse mattingly mais jeudi les
agriculteurs les pêcheurs l'industrie
agroalimentaire je fais déjà beaucoup de
français laurent fignon laurent fabius
avait moins de 40 ans quand il est entré
à matignon 41 ans savoure je suis jeune
du tout alors mais quand même
est-ce que
la ressource du quadra va s'imposer
selon vous au chef de l'état aujourd'hui
l'âge n'est pas une vertu là je n'ai pas
une vertu ce qui est une vertu c'est le
travail que l'on fait c'est la capacité
à occuper un poste qui vous a été confié
c'est ça qu'on attend de quelqu'un et là
je n'ai jamais eu une vertu c'est pas
parce que vous êtes jeunes que vous êtes
bien tous les jeunes ont vocation à
accueillir des personnes beaucoup plus
âgés font beaucoup mieux travail que
vous vous évoquez tout al'air copé
baroin qui était déjà à vos côtés lors
de vos premiers pas en politique on
parlait tout à l'heure du club des
quatre comment est né cet attelage
moi j'étais directeur de cabinet du
premier ministre et donc le directeur de
cabinet il travaille avec tous les
ministres il rend les arbitrages qui
sont pas les arbitrages les plus
importants qui sont rendus directement
par le premier ministre c'est là que
j'ai fait connaissance de françois
baroin des gens qu'on s'a copé que j'ai
fait connaissance de christian jacob on
s'est très bien entendu on s'est revu on
a échangé on a dîné ensemble et donc à
la base c'est vraiment une relation
amicale entre nous quatre et par
ailleurs je crois profondément au
caractère collectif de la politique n'a
pas vocation forcément politique a
échangé des piques des petites phrases
ou des critiques on peut aussi
travailler amicalement très bien merci
bruno le maire la semaine prochaine
invité de preuves par 3 françois bayrou
au banc soir à tous
moi non